قد نخرج في كثير من الاحيان لمسه حنان
نزعها عن كاهلنا اعداء وهم الحياه اليوميه
وهذا ما يفعله الاحباء او ما تقوم به
الامم تجاه ابنائها للتعبير لهم عن حبها
لكن ان تلمس ذلك لدى شخص غريب مقابل المال
فهذا ما لا تفعله سوى الامريكيه
وتحترف هيك التي تبلغ من العمر تسعه
وعشرين عاما وهي من سكان منطقه بورتلاند
بولايه اوريغون رسميا وظيفه المعانقه
مقابل ستين دولار من ساعه
وقد تبدو لوهله بانها وظيفه غريبه الا
انها تصر على انها تتطلب مهارات خاصه
ولتفادي الالتباس تقوم حيث بالالتقاء
بالزبون في مكان عام او لا لتحديد اطر
المعانقه البريئه تلك المناسبه لاحتضان
الاطفال كما تزعم وترهيب ان لكل شخص طريقه
احتضار مختلفه وتطلق على المعانقه مسميات
مختلفه منها تعالى الى ما ما ودراجه تندم